grande fusée écouter aujourd'hui ce que
vous êtes prêt pour une sortie en mer
c'est un jeu français le plus gros le
plus beau pardon spéculateurs des
simulateurs parce qu'en fait il tout
simplement des vraies images c'est parti
on est tout de suite plongé dedans c'est
un simulateur de noyade et j'ai moi pour
de vrai j'ai fait plein de cauchemars où
je me noyais et j'ai eu un peu peur de
l'eau dans la vie voilà je me confesse
avoue actuellement et sans déconner ça a
l'air ultra réalistes en plus ça en
français j'ai absolument envie de tester
ces partis au ces le gravity de la mer
oui j'ai une belle journée
ouais oh là là ouais tu prends la barre
de minutes sur la whey patriot act
hockey commence à tomber à l'eau c'est
que je me dis en fait à quel moment où
tu tombes tu es bien là bas voir une
tempête d'un coup césar non au missile a
accroché tout d'abord je fais quoi là
qu'est ce qu'il ya à quoi je fais quoi
ni ces prix là le poulet non il est dans
l'eau je crois au lait sans vous arrêter
pour vous maintenir à la surface
ces machines chez machine allait bien
bel et bien révolu mais tu jettes la
[ __ ] tu viens bordel tu as regardé one
mais simple regardez moi depuis c'est
sûr il a par ailleurs évoqué ce qu il se
barre
mais oui je sais trop comment j'ai
jamais trouvé comme ça mon gars ils se
parlent quand ils sont pas des steaks de
moins toi
oui pourquoi je suis tout émoustillé là
je vois pas pourquoi cet homme abandonné
attendait seul au milieu de l'océan mais
mes chances de survie -10% à l'état je
trouve comme un gros porc en fait le but
de séduire le plus longtemps possible
mais attend pour sa part 2 rouges biache
calme en train de musc et le bras gauche
est incroyable commencé plus calmement à
gauche de manière très efficace
head of age et archibald et à leshan
revient à xiangfan la blague
charles c'était perdre le sens de la
blague en plus et une blessée norme
pendant le match et je suis blessé il me
faut des soins et c'est pas le
requinquer monde soit bien aller s'il te
plaît cherche-t-il essai complet sur moi
ans et devient le mec il est déjà 1000
km quoi il est sur une île poser en
train de construire un abri il a rejoint
les mecs dose de forrest les dés de
strand et le dip excellent d'accord donc
on est vraiment en train de sourire et
sa pompe
il a une idée il a une idée d'accord a
retiré un peu de poids ou alors donc
juste et pas confort nous résistons
résistons résumait j'ai fait technique
de pro regardez alors des kardashian
moisson touche le ciel était un champ
proche cool un bon gars non non non non
non non non non en charge à sa mère
joyce hatto willow game non attendez du
carême en hiver j'ai dans le simulateur
et oui en fait je troll comme ça et on
voit ça fait comme ça attends je veux
savoir la fin d'année de 6 ans sort sa
partie a pu savoir voir un jeu d'acteurs
hollywoodiens
et quelle belle journée ouais ça mais en
fait c'est le faire rhodia sa voiture
vient de tomber à l'eau mais ça me fait
pas les caisses sans déconner vous avez
commencé loin en plus sous l'océan
on voit que dalle mon gars je vais
ténèbres robiza [ __ ] tu prends la
balle tu perds à 180 avec et tu vas au
petit cube avec le bateau après mais ça
mais mhadjou jure au but si c'est ma
[ __ ] regarder comment ces noix qu'est
ce que tu peux faire quand et comme ça
c'est le milieu de l'océan est certes un
peu noyé qu'est ce que je me demande
c'est quoi le meilleur réflexe c'est de
trouver une cloche pour pouvoir respirer
sous l'eau de tuer un poisson et de
respirer
son corps à l'exode pendant qui jette
ses chaussures je lui ai déjà vu j'ai
fait mon loyer une fois à la piscine
municipale
j'ai même cru que j'allais crever je
suis sorti de l'eau j'ai craché de l'eau
des poumons vaste et spectaculaire des
prix à la maison après ça je me cache
pas à fond hockey on a été là parfait
cette fois je jette pas la souris vous
en faites pas je veux ça recommence à et
ce qu'ils arrivent à être sauvées chez
pas par des pirates
allez allez allez allez non non non mais
non me tape sur les nerfs avec les
boutons sur le côté
ok c'est pour prendre et on en est et
alors cette fois je fais pas attention
promis je vous donnerai tous à mettre
une claque à un moment ça allait quand
même du coup qu'est ce qui peut faire et
si la construire un radeau tir match et
pas les petits débris qui passent là
dans la mer bim et ben ils auraient dû
prendre le lacets de ses chaussures
[ __ ] de bourse direct en mode survival
allez tu t'en sors julien voilà on en
était précisément là chaque fois bien
bruit ya un bruit assez un hélico mais
quoi qu est ce qui se passe non attends
il s'est pas fait choper par un poisson
quand même oui du carbure trop allez on
va entendre un petit bout du paquebot
qui font et défont le péché allez les
gars je crois qu'il a mal quelque part
il a froid et léglize les glaces est
jeune et qui sont peu ferme ce qu'on
peut faire cette situation va être ça me
fait paniquer qu'est ce que vous les
fouilles bordel une gamme de dover watch
je sais pas là bas c'est quoi ça il ya
deux visions on avait deux problèmes une
peluche dans le bordel vase et jeux jeux
basés je vois ils en ont indiqué assez
dégueulasse [ __ ] faut que je serai
comme un porc tu fais quoi tu fais quoi
sa mâchoire [ __ ] donc mon bien oh oui
non pas dans ces visions aller les mots
des mois ils passaient par là quand il
cherchait son père il aurait 48
processeurs sur le dos il sauver quoi
c'est quoi ça une vision encore une
vision des corbeaux n'ont m'aura pas
maintenant mourra pas maintenant ses
morts ses morts ses morts oui l'église
non non non je veux pas mourir je veux
pas mourir là si tu en as inventé mon
gars [ __ ] de plus en plus à l'est les
salles faysal fait ça fait ça le fait ah
non je vais mourir j'ai mûri en moi
c'est bon c'est bon il ya des sauveurs
mais qu il est descendu mac
sa poussée de scroll est bien là dans le
schéma n'en suis pas mort c'est un bug
et ben je vais me refaire tout jeu pour
la 20e fois où est le problème
aucun étudiant de congères [ __ ] ce à
quoi ce qui se passe bordel je donne
tout ce que j'ai à temps c'est plus
fatigant pour nos deux produits que pour
lui de nager je suis sûr c'est faux
bateau vienne en somme c'est sur un mec
qui transporte par exemple des iphone 1
est là et avec cette situation d' iphone
nous voyons un pinot shop
semag je suis pas mort je fais que du
crawl et mon gars mais non mais non chez
moi on en a
c'est la fin c'est la fin c'est bien les
tons mais le mieux c'est de ne pas
tomber je pu m'arrêter scolaire je me
serais allé jusqu'à la fin on est mort
c'est sa femme
sa femme c'est donc ça qu'on voit ton
nom ses enfants jusque rôle arrêté au
revoir basse jean michel fdp regarde est
of war et là tu pouvais totalement jeter
l'ancré t'arrêter un fdp
et voilà notre tête va toucher les fins
fonds de la mer vous vous êtes voyais au
bout de cinq minutes 40 watts en a bien
tenu là on a donné tout ce qu'on avait
en mer on se fatigue plus vite qu'on ne
le pense
ben oui même à la piscine municipale ans
fatigue vite à chaque sortie en mer
porté aux touches de sauvetage à c'est
ça le message de fin c'est ça la morale
et à la piscine n'oubliez pas vos
brassard hockey j'approuve tout avant ce
message mais malheureusement je vais
très peu à la mer 9 millions huit cent
quatre vingt une personnes ont fait ce
truc butin sénat au moca belge ans d
attente c'est le lot sur ce jeu hyper
particuliers belges pas si vous a plu on
était totalement immergé dans cet océan
dans lequel on est mort n'hésitez pas
venez vous ça vous appuyez sur ce que
vous très vite dans une prochaine
j'ai vraiment adoré c'est très haut ça
nous paraissait très prenant même si
malheureusement eu un milliard de
problèmes techniques
on s'en doutait mais notre projet de mer
ça me regarde et me portez vous bien jo
tout le monde- pis